bonjour et bienvenue dans les sept huit
week-ends l'émission consacrée aux
loisirs aux idées de sorties dans le
département tout de suite le sommaire de
votre émission
la nuit des musées est programmée ce
samedi dans toute la france les
structures ouvriront leurs portes en
soirée et proposeront des animations
ludiques vous recevront dans cette
édition anne sophie moreau du musée
promenade du parc de marly et lucie un
sauvageon à du musée de la ville de
saint quentin en yvelines dans notre
rubrique sorti coup de projecteur dans
son magazine sur le zoo de thoiry les
visiteurs peuvent observer en ce moment
des bébés wallaby des lémuriens des
zèbres ou des ouistitis plus
d'informations à suivre a plaisir à un
pique nique géant sont organisées ce
dimanche au coeur du parc du château de
12h à 18h chaque année l'événement
accueille un millier de personnes les
détails dans ce magazine
et puis à zoom sur la coupe de france de
cyclisme sur piste une compétition qui
se déroulera vendredi et samedi au
vélodrome national de saint quentin en
yvelines
on commence donc cette émission par la
nuit à des musées cette année
l'événement a lieu samedi soir avant de
détailler les programmes du musée
promenade de marly-le-roi et du musée de
la ville de saint quentin en yvelines
nous allons prendre la direction de la
maréchalerie de versailles et le centre
d'art contemporain sera ouvert jusqu'à
22 heures et proposera l'exposition au
mark johnson baptisé lacunes féconde
l'artiste joue avec les métaphores et
avec les végétaux les détails avec
sephora à namani 24 tonnes de terre et
de graminées sauvages ont envahi la
maréchalerie de versailles une sculpture
vivante
intitulé lacunes féconde réalisée par
l'artiste plasticien et architecte marc
johnson diplômé des beaux-arts de paris
et de l'école nationale supérieure
d'architecturé de paris malaquais
l'artiste propose une approche à la fois
sensible et abstraite des enjeux
bioéthiques
ici on est dans une problématique qui
ouvre à une certaine transversalité des
disciplines c'est un artiste qui
croisent dans ce projet en particulier
l'armée aussi l'archéologie la génétique
c'est cela aussi qui était intéressant
et singulier de sa part c'était de
tenter de créer à travers le dispositif
dans lequel on circule quitter ce
paysage donc végétalisée revégétaliser
où la nature reprend ses droits
c'était vraiment de traiter de ces
questions transversales l'oeuvre vivante
vient confronté l'art ancestral de
l'archéologie au progrès scientifique
pour l'artiste les principales
évolutions du 21e siècle en
nanotechnologies biotechnologies
sciences du cerveau et intelligence
artificielle vient de transformer demain
l'industrie la médecine et les
neurosciences
une intelligence artificielle
accompagnent d'ailleurs le visiteur dans
le dispositif en déclamant un texte
autour de l'avenir de l'activité humaine
et bien non de travail avec institut
national de recherches archéologiques
préventives
il s'agit de comprendre comment les
technologies aujourd'hui notamment
l'apport de la génétique en archéologie
va pouvoir transformer le vivant et pose
des questions fondamentales pour nous
aujourd'hui
comme l'interaction des technologies
avec notre corps propre les
neurosciences et donc des questions
philosophiques comme le mouvement
culturel notamment le transhumanisme le
post humanisme les études de marc
johnson sur le sujet ont amené à
l'édition prochaine d'un livre sur la
bioéthique et pour les visiteurs
désireux de s'approprier ce sujet un
questionnaire de vingt-et-une question
est distribuée pour prolonger la
réflexion philosophique et scientifique
on reste dans la thématique de la nuit
des musées focus sur deux événements qui
seront proposées ce week-end dans les
yvelines
nous recevons sur ce plateau l'uci a
sauvageons la responsable des actions
culturelles au musée de la ville de
saint quentin en yvelines pour ça
bonjour et nous recevons également anne
sophie moreau a chargé à des publics au
musée promenade de marly le roi nous
cherchons alors nous avons tout eu de
commencer par vous à lucie sauvageons
quelle sera la programmation du musée de
la ville pour cette nuit spéciale pour
cette nuit des musées c'est un peu
particulier cette année on ne propose
une exposition de préfiguration du futur
musée puisque le musée de la ville va
déménager on va pas très loin on va
juste en face dans le bâtiment la
médiathèque du canal mais du coup c'est
un nouveau projet qui sera présenté
donc c'est une exposition qui présente
futurs projets et puis avec aussi la
complicité d'artistes qui sont des
artistes associés à la commanderie des
templiers de lavilledieu à elancourt qui
ont travaillé sur des installations
artistiques autour du thème du musée
imaginaire donc on est vraiment dans le
thème de l'imaginaire imaginaire et dudu
de qu'est-ce qu'un musée comment le
conçois comme on l'imaginé pourquoi
avoir imaginé ce thème alors vraiment
parce que c'est le rapprochement entre
la nuit nuit des musées le rêve
et puis le fait que nous on est en train
de faire ce travail de conception d'un
futur musée et qu'on voulait réfléchir
aussi avec avec
visiteurs et avec des gens qui viendront
sur comment on conçoit amuser comme on
l'imaginé mais qu'est ce que vous
aimeriez que les gens retiennent cet
événement les thématiques sur lesquelles
on travaille d'abord parce que c'est pas
toujours évident mais aussi qu'il voit
l'ensemble des missions du musée parce
qu'en général on les voit difficilement
il y en a beaucoup qui sont cachés tout
ce qui est conservation évidemment tout
l'aspect gestion des collections donc
c'est aussi ça qu'on veut mettre en
avant
et puis surtout qu'ils participent à ces
installations artistiques et qu'ils en
profitent pour voir nos collections et
c'est un événement important pour votre
structure cette nuit des musées c'est un
événement très important et structurant
on a deux à chaque fois liste sur
l'année dernière en ce moment la nuit
des musées auxquelles on participe tous
les ans comme la plupart des musées de
france
et puis les journées du patrimoine qui
sont les deux grands événements qui
rythment habituellement notre
programmation
les journées du patrimoine étant à
l'extérieur vraiment la valorisation du
patrimoine sur le terrain la nuit des
musées c'est vraiment notre événement
propre à la structure muséale et ça
permet peut-être de renouer le lien avec
les jeunes générations
oui ça permet d'attirer des publics un
petit peu différent on a c'est un
événement qui est fait pour être
convivial qui en soirée sur un temps
différent c'est toujours des
propositions qui sont en général plus
original un peu différente et inédite
qui nous permette de souvent toucher un
public plus jeune que le la moyenne des
visiteurs habituels un public on voit
pas forcément en temps ordinaire au
musée et de surtout de mélanger vraiment
tous ses visiteurs et les derniers
énormément de monde nous attendait
autant de monde cette année
on peut naître ainsi pas moi on entend
autant de monde après c'est toujours un
petit peu plus compliqué puisqu'on est
en pleine période de transition donc
c'est le rythme change un petit peu pour
nous donc
ne sait pas exactement combien de
personnes répondront à l'appel mais
c'est toujours en général un événement
qui est très suivie et je pense que
comme tous les ans on aura du monde au
musée soir là on va passer à présent au
musée promenade de marly alors cette
soirée sera placée sous le signe de
cervantès et notamment de dom quichotte
exactement alors avoir choisi ce thème
plus don quichotte que cervantès en fait
l'année dernière le musée a acquis une
tapisserie qui dans son tableau central
représente un épisode de l'histoire de
don quichotte don quichotte connaît un
grand succès justement au xviiie siècle
alors que l'oeuvre paraît au tout début
du xviie et donc on a choisi de
valoriser cette tapisserie et on a
construit notre programmation autour du
thème de don quichotte et on l'a
déclinée sous différentes formes à
travers des lectures théâtralisées à
travers de la musique
et puis des projections et un atelier
destiné aux chaînes publiques des
projections est ce que vous nous en dire
un peu plus alors en fait puisqu'on est
partie 2
du succès de don quichotte et de toutes
les réinterprétations qui se sont
succédé dans le temps
faisant de recherche on a vu que jacques
brel s'était enfin avait une fascination
pour don quichotte et avait créé la
comédie musicale l'homme de la mancha et
donc on a retrouvé deux reportages où
justement j'aimerais leur raconte
pourquoi don quichotte le fascine et
comment aussi on voit quelques images de
la comédie musicale
alors malheureusement elle n'a jamais
été filmées à priori dans son
intégralité donc on n'a que quelques
extraits mais ça donne aussi quand même
une idée de ce projet différent de
jacques brel par rapport à la carrière
qu'on lui connaît les bobbies également
un public assez jeune on vise un public
assez jeune à travers un atelier qui
leur sera destiné puisque le thème jeux
pour les jeunes les plus jeunes
notamment le l'affluence en valeur plus
coriace que l'atelier destiné aux plus
jeunes
lucile a dit la nuit des musées c'est
souvent un public familial et on sait
que entre eux écouter de la musique
c'est plaisant mais les enfants peuvent
avoir une main une petite impatience
donc on a décidé de proposer un atelier
de création d'un petit moulin puisque
quand on pense dans qui chatte on pense
forcément moulin et donc on est un
artiste qui toute la soirée accompagnera
les plus jeunes pour à la fois
décoré ce moulin il la veut créer en 3d
pour participer à toutes et toutes les
activités tous les ateliers il faut
quand même temps alors en fait la
programmation est conçu de telle sorte
que on invite le public à rester toute
la soirée puisque à travers les lectures
théâtralisées
on va avoir trois temps de lecture de 20
minutes et l'idée c'est que si on reste
eh bien on aura de nouveau toute
l'histoire de don quichotte en tête
on n'est pas parti du texte de cervantes
qui est un petit peu aride
on est parti d'une pièce de théâtre de
victorien sardou qui est un auteur du
19e siècle que personne ne plus personne
ne connaît en fait l'auteur de madame
sans gêne c'est une pièce de théâtre qui
en général dit quelque chose c'est un
auteur extrêmement populaire qui a vécu
à marly et donc on est parti de cette
pièce de théâtre et pour l'occasion n'a
également de sortie nous réserve des
oeuvres qui parle de victorien sardou
ce n'est pas votre première mieux de
musées quels sont les retours en général
sur cette mue alors en général c'est des
retours très positifs parce que c'est
justement un public du différend qui
découvre aussi nos collections sous un
nouvel angle qui découvrent parfois tout
simplement le musée aussi parce que
l'uci l'a dit le fait qu'on qu'on
propose quelque chose de différent par
rapport au regard plutôt des journées du
patrimoine où on accueille les visiteurs
un petit peu en fluo constant là on est
à leur écoute on leur propose des petits
moments particuliers donc en général de
très bons retours l'année dernière grand
succès aussi au musée promenade donc
nous attendons encore beaucoup de monde
cette année on espère bien suivre encore
beaucoup de monde comme tout le monde
merci à tous les deux être passé sur ce
plateau vous souhaite évidemment d'avoir
beaucoup de monde pour cette nuit à des
musées on referme à présent cette page
par deux rendez vous le château de
versailles organise une nocturne inédite
pour cette douzième nuit des musées les
grandes écuries du roi sont ouvertes
pour la première fois de 19h à 1h du
matin les visiteurs pourront découvrir
la galerie des carrosses et pourront
assister à des démonstrations équestres
avec un spectacle de dressage
à noter également le parking sera
gratuit sur la place d'armes enfin le
musée de la toile de jouer implantée à
jouy en josas proposera un atelier
d'initiation la teinture ce samedi de
18h à 23h les apprentis réaliseront dans
la structure des impressions avec des
plantes les astuces vous seront donnés
pour reproduire cette expérience à la
maison après cette large
page nuit à des musées on ouvre notre
rubrique sortie on prend à présent la
direction du zoo de thoiry dans cette
émission le printemps rime avec
naissance au parc ce week-end les
visiteurs pourront observer des bébés un
wallaby des ouistitis des oryx d'arabie
des lémuriens ou encore des zèbres un
montage de xavier jamin la famille
touahri s'agrandit le parc zoologique
yvelinois qui recense plus de 800
animaux et 120 espèces enregistré 37
naissances en 2016 dont une dizaine
depuis le début du mois de mai on essaie
aussi de faire en sorte que les
naissances arrive à un moment où c'est
aussi le plus facile pour la survie du
petit c'est à dire qu'un petit petites
antilopes qui va naître en plein hiver
quand il fait moins dix ses chances de
survie sont un petit peu plus faible que
si l'aînée maintenant et que ben il a
tout l'été pour devenir un peu plus fort
et donc aborder l'hiver un peu plus
facilement évidemment ça coïncide avec
la période où le public est là on va pas
s'en plaindre
c'est forcément plus intéressant pour un
visiteur de voir de voir des animaux des
bébés
cette année les quatre cent mille
visiteurs annuels pourront observer des
bébés wallaby des ouistitis des zèbres
des bises ou encore des oryx d'arabie
cacher le plus souvent dans les pattes
de leur mère ces naissances sont
toujours bien accueillis par les 60
employés du parc c'est pas forcément un
critère de que l'animal est bien parce
que les animaux c'est ça fait partie de
leur vie de se reproduire
donc voilà les autres animaux vous
mettez un bal une semaine globalement
souvent ça va se reproduire mais
évidemment quelle que soit la naissance
on est content donc là quand on a des
petits des petits du goût des petits
chevaux des petits trucs comme ça c'est
oui forcément mécontent de nouvelles
naissances devraient avoir lieu dans les
prochaines semaines chez les zèbres les
antilopes et légumes où chaque année le
parc accueille entre 70 et 80 nouveaux
pensionnaires c'est désormais une
tradition à plaisir ce dimanche un pique
nique géant est organisé dans le parc du
château de 12h à 18h chaque année l
événement attire un millier de personnes
si le soleil est au rendez vous pour
nous parler de cet événement nous
recevons sur ce plateau brice voir un
métairie conseiller municipal délégué
aux actions culturelles
bonjour
alors pourquoi organiser un pique nique
géant à plaisir organise un pique nique
géant à plaisir c'est un petit peu notre
lancement notre coup d'envoi de nos
beaux jours culturel ça permet de aussi
faire découvrir cet écran souvent ou via
un plaisir on connaît ikea vont cogner
au chant mais on oublie un peu le
château et le parc du château ça permet
de bien nous faire découvrir notre ville
différemment et donc pour cette journée
spéciale technique il y aura une app
exact exactement vous avez apporté avec
vous sur ce plateau exactement une nappe
une app quiz napoli et où en fait il ya
des effectivement des questions c'est en
partenariat avec eco emballages et 400
abscons distribué l'année dernière on en
avait même pas suffisamment puisque ça
attire effectivement vous l'avez ok plus
d'un millier de personnes tous les ans
berthod pour avoir sa marque il faut
venir tôt pour avoir sa nappe exactement
et il y aura également des animations
des animations de découverte de la pêche
et un jardin des senteurs qui sera
présentée par le service environnement
de la ville et l'événement est gratuit
oui d'accord il est important et c'est
pour ces pour tous les plaisirs oit si
vous également pour d'autres personnes
qui habitent les communes des alentours
c'est pour tous les plaisirs way salut
au delà l'important c'est ce que je
disais tout à l'heure c'est de vraiment
faire découvrir cet écrin de plaisir le
centre-ville de plaisir le château et
son parc
donc c'est vraiment ouvert à tous
expliquez-nous une journée type pour un
plaisir à qui veut se rendre au château
du coup à midi voilà il arrive à me
l'expliquer abou bakr sinon
effectivement il y aura plus forcément
plus de nappes
l'idée c'est d'arriver au niveau du
château de prendre sa nappe et de
s'installer où il le souhaite dans le
parc du château et de profiter d'un
moment agréable normalement ce week-end
non plus il est censé faire beau donc
c'est vraiment profiter de ce moment en
famille entre amis est vraiment
découvrir cet endroit et chaque p 0 ap
vient avec sa nourriture de courtes oui
d'accord c'est important effectivement
la ville de plaisir met à disposition
des nappes met également à disposition
des animations qui sont gratuites
par contre effectivement faut venir avec
son pique nique et donc c'est la sixième
édition si je ne me trompe pas sixième
édition est ce qu'il y aura d'autres à
l'avenir
oui comme je l'évoquais tout à l'heure
ce ce pique nique géant c'est vraiment
le notre coup d'envoi nos beaux jours
culturel donc c'est vraiment important
et c'est quelque chose qui perdura nom
de ton sans aucun doute
merci à vous d'être passé sur ce plateau
je rappelle aux téléspectateurs le pique
nique géant de plaisir c'est ce dimanche
à partir de midi on passe maintenant
nature rubrique la littérature
direction à présent le pavé du canal
comme chaque semaine la librairie vous
fait découvrir un nouveau roman
cette semaine zoom sur land folle de
hélène urbany pas paru aux éditions
gallmeister un livre sur les sinistrés
de l'ouragan katrina qui a ravagé les
chutes des états unis en 2005
regardez je te présenter un nouveau
roman des éditions gallmeister qu'on
aime beaucoup déjà à la librairie c'est
un premier roman d'une une jeune
écrivain là elle va nous parler d'un
élément qui est au moins aussi marquant
que les attentats du 11 septembre c'est
l'ouragan katrina
donc on va suivre deux personnages une
jeune femme qui s'appelle rose qui est
une jeune blanche qui part avec sa mère
aider les réfugiés de la nouvelle
orléans qui fuit l'ouragan et qui fila
destructions et les pillages et en
parallèle on va sur l'histoire de rozic
est une jeune afro-américaine qui elle
vient de la nouvelle orléans qui a perdu
sa mère dans le grand stade de la
nouvelle orléans et qui va partir à la
recherche de ses racines pour essayer de
faire libérer sa mère ses deux femmes
vont se rencontrer à un moment un moment
assez tragique qui va permettre à toutes
les deux de retrouver leurs racines de
s'interroger sur sur l'endroit d'où
elles viennent de leurs relations
surtout avec leur mère ce sont deux
filles qui vivent seules avec leur maman
y'a pas de pair voilà l ces fonds se
poser plein de questions sur qui elles
sont et quelle est leur place dans la
société américaine aujourd'hui on
retrouve quand même l'ambiance de la
nouvelle orléans la solidarité entre les
gens les différences aussi de richesse
il ya vraiment des gens qui vivaient
dans une extrême pauvreté et qui
arrivait à vivre avec trois fois rien et
qui évidemment eu du mal à s'en sortir
et cuba tous ceux qui avaient les bonnes
voitures les bons contacts etc ont
réussi à fuir avant avant l'arrivée de
catherine d'accord pour une bonne perles
de galles master est comme d'habitude
très bien
le temple du cyclisme sont français sera
une nouvelle fois le théâtre d'une
compétition de haut niveau ce week-end
la coupe de france fenioux est
programmée de ce vendredi 20 mai à ce
samedi à 21 mai au vélodrome national de
saint quentin en yvelines
au total 18 à nations seront
représentées parmi les têtes d'affiché
on retrouvera le riz bertand
vice-championne du monde en février
dernier l'anglais jason kenny qui a
également gagné plusieurs médailles aux
jeux olympiques et grégory baugé neuf
fois champion du monde un beau plateau
nous avons rencontré le pistard de
l'équipe de france françois pervis et
110 clair nous sommes avec les pistards
de l'équipe de france handi claire et
françois pervis nous allons parler de la
coupe de france qui se tiendra ce
week-end à saint quentin en yvelines
alors 110 cette coupe de france
c'est un rendez vous important dans
votre calendrier mais cette coupe de
france va nous permettre de voir où on
en est par rapport à notre pas dire un
autre formé par rapport à nos chronos
parce que là on est en pleine
préparation aux jeux donc on n'a pas
forcément préparé ce grand prix
maintenant on va voir les chronos que ça
donne et on va pouvoir peaufiner bat
pour la suite françois vous êtes
d'accord avec 110 oui c'est exactement
ça l'a bien résumé le le pourquoi de
cette coupe de france
et puis surtout aussi pour nous ça va
être aussi une
nouvelle occasion de faire de la
tactique de course parce que des fois il
se peut nous arriver de ne pas courir
pendant six mois et fait tout ça les
feelings de course les le placement dans
le dans les sprints
ça peut ça peut se perdre donc ça sera
une bonne occasion aussi de pratiquer la
tactique de course et le plateau sera
relevé c'est au canon ya vraiment un
beau plateau
oui il ya un beau plateau bon bah nous
il ya toute l'équipe de france déjà et
puis ensuite les étrangers bon il ya des
polonais qui ont marché très fort tout
cet hiver
et puis aussi surtout le champion du
monde et champion olympique jason kenny
l'anglais donc ça va être intéressant de
voir lui aussi ou est ce qu'il en est
c'est un test du coup pour vous pour en
vue des jo c'est vraiment un test où
c'est encore dans votre préparation
alors on va se servir de cette
compétition là pour voir comme le disait
110 ou est-ce qu'on en est physiquement
et puis
un test un petit test mais on va pas en
tirer de grandes conclusions c'est juste
pour voir où est ce qu'on en est
actuellement et pour pour gérer au mieux
la suite du programme d'entraînement
sans ni le fait que ça soit ici au
vélodrome de saint-quentin-en-yvelines
c'était inéluctable
on peut le dire c'est vrai que c'est
sympa parce que bon c'est notre piste on
roule tous les jours dessus donc on
connaît cette piste par coeur
et voilà il ya des proches qui vont
pouvoir venir nous voir donc ça c'est
aussi important même si c'est une
compétition pas très importante dans le
calendrier international
c'est quand même
enfin important que nos proches puissent
venir nous soutenir et puis voilà se
remettre un peu en jambes au niveau de
la compétition parce que voilà notre
dernière compét c'était les mondiaux
donc comme disait françois ça date un
peu
donc du coup voilà vous attendez du
monde du coût de votre famille ma
famille pas particulièrement parce que
comme ils sont dans le sud ça fait un
peu loin juste pour un week-end mais par
contre j'ai d'autres d'autres amis qui
vont venir vous visez un temps en
particulier peut-être sur non moi c'est
vraiment voir où j'en suis voilà c'est
vraiment voir où j'en suis et on verra
je sais très bien que je ferai pas de
record enfin bon on sait jamais jamais
non non mais voilà c'est vraiment pour
voir où j'en suis françois même chose ya
pa de temps précis a pas d'objectif sur
cette compétition pour vous non mais bon
si par exemple sur le dos en salle
organisé oui on veut toujours gagner on
est compétiteur dans l'âme
tout sportif de haut niveau s'entraîne
pour gagner ses courses
donc voilà c'est juste faire un bon 200
mètres voir où est ce que j'en suis
faire un bon chrono essayons de
descendre sous les 10 secondes
parce que c'est une piste comme
relativement rapide pour pour les 200 m
lancé
et puis ensuite comme j'ai dis vraiment
pratiqué faire la tactique de course
parce que c'est important de de toujours
aiguisé les sa tactique on leur a dit
spectacle le premier tech il y aura
forcément du spectacle j'ai sont
attendus monde on espère qu'il y aura
beaucoup de monde ça c'est très
important aussi pour le spectacle
soit soit de qualité donc on attend on
attend du public on espère que public
viendra viendra nombreux sans dire en 30
secondes
est-ce que vous pouvez nous donner envie
de venir voir cette coupe de france
et ben moi j'attends tous les supporters
et supportrices pour venir nous soutenir
parce que comme dit françois c'est
important ça nous donne vraiment envie
de nous dépasser donc on vous attend sur
cette coupe de france est forcément oui
il y aura du spectacle parce que de
toute façon la piste c'est un spectacle
merci à tous les deux merci beaucoup le
sport on termine ce magazine parle du
cinéma
en plein festival de cannes luc beaucamp
dû signer cette d'elancourt nous
présente son coup de coeur de la semaine
coup de projecteur aujourd'hui sur marie
et les naufragés avec eric cantona alors
le coup de coeur de 6,17 cette semaine
c'est un petit fils votre guy m j'aime
pas employer cette expression quand je
dis petit film c'est parce qu'il est
sorti sur trop peu d'écrans à mon sens
c'est marie est naufragé
donc c'est un fils de sébastien joly
begbeider avec pierre rochefort ville
vimala pons qu'on avait déjà dans comme
un avion de bruno podalydès
et puis eric cantona donc c'est une
histoire un peu légères un peu loufoque
l'histoire d'un homme joué par rochefort
qui rencontrent donc plutôt à mon refus
de cette jeune femme qui est selon son
ex jouer avec suavité par eric cantona
qui se trouve prend de l'épaisseur de
roullens roule et dangereux est jugé
dangereux je ne vous en dis pas plus
c'est une comédie douce ni phoques qui
nous emmène sur l'île de groix donc on
voyage on se balade un petit peu en
france c'est très très bien interprété
c'est très sympa et c'est à découvrir
dans les salles cette semaine que sera
l'issue de ce voyage
on passe à présent aux autres sorties de
la semaine il ya du choix dans les
salles obscures en ont c'est un très
très bonne en b2b super ne s'est
vraiment bien
oh moi j'ai aimé parce que bon c'est un
film qui lance un message quand même sur
le monde des traders de la finance de
tout ce qui se passe qu'on ne sait pas
quoi
oui oui ça m'a bien plu c'est ya du
suspense
c'est très bien interprété évidemment
puisque la journée
roberts voilà c'est un bon film pour moi
c'est complètement déjanté mais c'est
super drôle et très très bien tourner
les comédiens sont excellents
c'est la fin de ce set 8 week end merci
d'avoir suivi je retrouve lundi pour le
7-8 sport très bon week-end sur tv fil